devant quelques instants on va parler de
ce qui vous entoure will poole que vous
avez eu que vous avec le deuxième volet
de votre enquête nous allons constater
en tout cas que dans les supermarchés le
chocolat n'est pas forcément moins cher
dans les grandes surfaces ont fait même
tout pour piéger les plus jeunes
consommateurs reportage que vous avez
réalisé le diabète avec daniel lice
jérémy six ans et demi et gwenaël le
vent deux jeunes gourmands livrée à elle
même au rayon des chocolats qu'est ce
que ça donne un choix rapide et plutôt
raisonnable six articles chacun avec
plusieurs grands classiques lapin
poissons petits oeufs mais gwenaëlle ne
résiste pas à barbie et jérémy à sa
passion pour le foot
modifier un vendeur doit grands soirs
comme ça tourne à québec là où le blick
la menace d'un combat des chocolats là
tu vas aller les trouver en fait tu vas
on trouve les noms chez toi dans ta
maison tu vas manger tout ça va pas trop
bien le jour là trois dans chaque panier
il y en a tout de même pour près de 400
francs c'est nettement au-dessus du
budget de la plupart des adultes y vais
en acheter pour mes quatre
petits-enfants oui mais pas beaucoup
dans une petite chose parce que oui je
me limiterai ville
je penserai maximum 100 francs pour les
quatre pour les quatre russes
ce qui fait grimper les prix ce sont les
marques bien sûr et cette année elles
ont décidé de célébrer pâques en force
ça plaît énormément en dessous de 10 ans
mais nettement mois au dessus de 30
quand on est parent une grands parents
on a du mal à payer jusqu'à 300 francs
le kilo un simple fond chocolat le
contenant une babiole